I I know that I loved theater but I was
really open to all of it I remember
someone coming into drama school to like
to just talk to us as final year
students and saying your first couple of
years out of here take whatever comes in
your direction don't be picky don't be
this don't be that just take what comes
and and it's exactly what I did and I
learned you know that I enjoy you know
working on camera I I enjoy being on set
um and I still love going to the theater
and I still love being part of a play
and um as the years have gone on you
know I've done probably three
professional plays in 20 nearly 25 years
wow and the rest of it has been camera
work um and that's not necessarily by
choice cuz one thing I do know is that I
will always go back to the theater I'm
I'm at a stage now where I'm like
plotting when that's going to happen
next but for me as an actor I kind of
feel like theater is like rehab for
acting when you've done a lot of work on
set and on screen um you you you know
things like the rehearsal room and that
space for like 4 weeks it feels like a
gift these days because you have zero
rehearsal time when you when you're
certainly when you're doing a TV show
you really you rehearse on the day and
then you know for like 20 minutes and
then you show it to a crew and it's like
this is how we're doing it and you have
to have made a lot of choices and
decisions and things before you even got
there whereas that exploratory sort of
you know going into the rehearsal room
finding things was trying things out
building it all from the ground up and
then presenting it um and then having
the immediate audience you know
gratification if you're in a comedy
getting a laugh is like the biggest
thing in the world I love that side of
it absolutely but then you I remember
the grind I remember like doing the
eight shows a week and you know you're
in a theater production you're like
Jesus how long have we got left another
six weeks of this going to do that thing
D and out yeah so you know like every
actor never pleased never
never never fully satisfied yeah but I
love all of it and I'm glad that I
started in the theater yeah that's good
anybody you worked with or went to
school with um have they had success oh
sure I mean my best friend at drama or
one of had sort of a circle of very
tight friends at drama school um but one
of them was James makoy oh wow I don't
know if you've heard of him yes I've
heard of James makoy and we're still you
know really good mates we don't see each
other as much as we used to because you
know we live in different sides of the
world you acted with him on oh yeah I
did my first ever professional gig with
James which was a panto a pantomim sorry
in uh in kardi in faith in Scotland uh
it was our final year of drama school
and the drama school were doing a
pantomim because that's a big thing in
the UK um and but they said to any final
year students if you want to audition
for any professional pantos you're
allowed to do that so James and I both
auditioned for this panto Beauty and the
Beast and we both got it and and it was
a musical it was music pantos have
always got music in them yeah pantos I
didn't know that and uh and they've
always got like they've they've always
got like stock characters in them
whatever the story is that year well
it's always a fairy tale but there's
always like um the Dame which is a man
dressed as a woman uh there's always the
lead uh the I think the lead boy which
is always a woman just as a man and then
there's always a character which we
would call the buttons character cuz
that's a character from Cinderella but
they're kind of like the sidekick who
who' always like get the audience going
cuz it's always direct address to the
audience and stuff um it's very
interactive experience and James was
that character he played Bobby Buck fast
and I played the Beast and the
prince so do you still remember the the
songs the music all that I mean yeah
there were songs that were taken the
what normally happens in panto is they
take relevant pop songs and they change
the lyrics of them uh or they take songs
from musicals and change lyrics like
what give me an example well I you don't
have to sing but you can no no I mean um
if I were a bell which is from I can't
remember that which musical that's from
originally but that was in R1 I remember
my song that I had to do was a um A
House Is Not a Home a chair is still a
chair Bert
barer House Is Not a Home is that right
a chair is still a chair even if there's
no one sitting there that's amazing um
and yeah so Weir you always have that
like ear for like being on
is that something that you're born with
because I I I A lot of times I have a
band and sunspin and you know I I'll say
you know a home is not a home and my Rob
go off key SM smile smile when you're
saying